how do you think people thought about
the idea
how do they Square the idea of all men
are created equal those very powerful
words uh at the founding of this nation
how do they square that with slavery
for many Americans saying all men were
created equal required slavery because
it meant that uh the equality of white
people was dependent upon others doing
the work for us in the way some people
View Animal labor today and maybe in 50
years we'll see that as a contradiction
but the notion among many Americans in
the 17th 18th century and this would
also be true for those in other
societies was that equality for white
men
meant that you had access to the labor
of others that would allow you to
equalize other differences
so uh you could produce enough food so
your family could live equally well
nourished as other families because you
had slaves on the land doing the farming
for you this is Thomas Jefferson's world
so it's like animal farm all animals are
equal but some are more equal than
others that's right and I think that's
that's still the way people view things
yeah right I don't know if that's a
that's a liberal position or it's just a
human position that um
that all humans have equal value
just on the basic level of like of
humanity
but do we really believe that I we want
to I don't know ourselves I don't know
if our society really believes that yet
and I don't know exactly I mean it's
super complicated of course
um when you realize the amount of
suffering that's going on in the world
where there's children dying from
starvation in Africa and to say that all
humans are equal well a few dollars can
save that life and and instead we buy a
Starbucks coffee and we are willing to
pay 10 50 100 000 to save a child our
child like uh somebody from our family
and don't want to spend two dollars to
save a child over in Africa right so
there's and uh I think Sam Harris or
others I've talked about like well I
want I don't want to live in a world
where we'd rather send two dollars to
Africa there's something deeply human
about saving those that are really close
to you the ones we love so that like
hypocrisy
that seems to go attention with the
basic ethics of alleviating suffering in
the world that's also really human
that's also part of this ideal
of all men are created equal it's a
complicated messy World ethically it it
is but I mean I think at least the way I
think about it is so what are the things
even within our own Society
where we choose to do something with our
resources that actually doesn't help the
lives of many people so we we invest in
all kinds of things that are often
because someone is lobbying for them
this happens on both sides of the aisle
this is not a political statement right
rather than saying you know if we
invested a little more of our money
really a little more we could make sure
every child in this country had decent
Health Care
we can make sure every child in this
country had what they need needed to
start life healthy
and that would not require us to
sacrifice a lot but it would require us
to sacrifice a few things
yeah there's a balance there and I also
noticed the passive aggressive statement
you're making about how I'm spending my
money you know me too spending it a
little more wisely
I I you know I like to eat the nice
meals at nice restaurants uh so I'm I'm
as guilty of this as you are
I got a couch and that couch serves no
purpose it looks nice though no it's so
nice it's a nice looking couch it's
actually very clean I got it for
occasional Instagram photos to look like
an adult